- What's up Believe Nation?
Today we're going to
talk about seven new ways
to make money on the side.
(upbeat music)
So I get asked this question a lot.
How do I make money on the side?
How do I turn my job into a business?
That then I can get my
side hustle up first
and then create a full-time
income off of that.
Or how do I take my business
and add something a little bit on the side
to help me grow.
So today I'm going to give you
my seven ways for making
money on the side.
(instrumental music)
Way number one is to volunteer.
Wait, what.
I thought you said I'm
making money on the side.
Now you're telling me to volunteer.
Volunteering and creating spec work
is one of the greatest
ways to get opportunities
to help you develop a relationship.
So as an example I look at videos,
you guys like my videos.
You're watching this video now.
One of the guys that did some video work,
his name was Rich.
And he started off by making a Believe
by YouGottaLove on the channel.
And he volunteered and
created that video for me.
Since then he's come
in and done some videos
on spec where he was on camera.
And he was also behind the camera filming.
I've done some videos for his channel.
And we expanded that to him getting paid
to create some videos for the channel.
He was into a certain kind of video,
some motivational videos,
and he had an idea that matched up
with something I wanted to create.
And then I hired him to make
some videos for the channel.
And so that spec work,
that volunteer work,
led to a relationship,
which led to me hiring him.
Sticking with the video world,
I think about Gary Vaynerchuk
and how his videographer
a guy named DRock pitched him
on doing a video series.
Said hey I think you should
be filming your content.
I think you got to be out there.
You're a thought leader.
I want to help.
I'm a videographer.
He did one project.
He did one video.
I think it was a clouds and
dirt video on Gary's channel.
And it took off and it did well
and Gary loved it.
He said you know what I like this.
I'm going to hire you to come on and be,
it ended up being a full-time job,
full-time career for him.
And it worked.
And so a lot of times to get in the door
you got to prove yourself.
And a great way to be able to do it
is to volunteer to do some spec work
to show that listen I got talents,
I got skills,
that help build your portfolio.
But ideally you're working with companies
and with people who can
turn into paying clients
after the initial project is done.
(instrumental music)
Number two is to be a connector.
I'd been looking at what
are some opportunities
that are out where I can be a salesperson
with businesses or individuals
that I know have a need.
So as an example,
I look at here trying to dance salsa.
One of my assistants at the school,
her name is Claudia,
she has a business where she's
reselling internet services.
And so she's talking to the companies
that she's connected with.
And I want to help her out.
I'm actually paying more
to work with Claudia
than I would from my
normal internet provider
because I want to support her.
I want to support her business,
her mission, what she's on.
And she has a full-time job.
And this may become something
that becomes a bigger
part of her career path.
And maybe it doesn't.
But I'm doing it 'cause
I want to support her.
And all she's doing is
being a connector, right.
She introduced me to the service provider.
And she gets a monthly commission
for every time I spend money
paying my monthly internet bill.
And so you can do that.
You can look at who is
already in that work
who you know has a need.
Go help them solve that problem
and take a commission off
of every sale that's made.
If you really love doing that
and you go all in on it.
That can be your start.
Just start selling other services
taking commission at the start.
But the more you get to
know these businesses,
the more you care about helping them,
the more you really
understand their problems,
the more pain that you see there,
the more of an opportunity it creates
for you to find other
services to help them.
So you don't have to create
anything from scratch
at the start.
You're just being a connector
bringing two parties together
who could use each other.
Number three is extend
somebody else's offering.
So whatever product or service
that you can potentially
bring to a company,
I'd be looking at how can I extend
somebody's existing offering.
So can you build an app
for somebody who is a thought leader,
and wants to get into
potentially the app business.
You know if you sell t-shirts,
can you be the t-shirt
provider for this person
who know can potentially
expand their business.
Like at TDS we're looking
at bringing in t-shirts
for the students,
and for the instruction,
and for the helpers.
I'm actually struggling
to find a local company
that doesn't suck with their service.
To give money to to help me make t-shirts.
Can you look at how can you extend
somebody's current business,
help them make more money,
help them grow into a new market,
by working with you on
a new potential project.
If it's too far outside their realm
then maybe it's not a fit.
But if there's a natural logical
extension of their business
then it's worth reaching out
and showing what you can do.
(instrumental music)
Number four is sell your sawdust.
I've been looking at what are
the things that you are doing
in your day-to-day activities,
things that you throw away,
that you may be able to sell.
So as an example look at
my high school cafeteria
and one of the things that we would do
back in high school,
back in the day,
is any extra food we had,
we would throw into a special garbage bin.
So we have a garbage bin for the garbage,
and a garbage bin for the food.
And then the school sold that excess food
to farms where they would feed
it to pigs and other animals.
And so selling your sawdust,
is an analogy for selling your garbage,
selling your waste product.
Sawdust was considered
a waste product right.
You're cutting wood,
there's sawdust on the floor.
That's garbage, you throw it away.
You realize hey I can actually sell that.
And make some money off of it.
So look at your current process.
Look at what you're currently making.
In your business as a product or service.
And look at the things that
you just take for granted.
Things that you just throw away.
Things that is just
considered a waste product.
And see how can I potentially
sell that to other people?
So another example is people
who are selling eBooks
based off their knowledge,
so people who have built up a business.
They've created a
successful YouTube channel.
And the product is the YouTube videos.
The product is the things
that you consume on a day
to day basis on YouTube.
The sawdust would be the entire process
of picking the right camera.
And getting better on camera themselves.
And the gear,
and the strategy,
and the SEO and all that stuff.
That could be turned into an eBook.
It could be turned into a
mastermind session, coaching,
it could be turned into
a physical book, right.
It's the byproduct of your
actual product or service.
So the stuff that you know,
the stuff that you maybe take for granted.
The stuff that you're just throwing away
or saying ah I know that already
can be turned into a product or service
that you could sell to other.
(instrumental music)
Number five is solve a problem.
At the end of the day
business is about solving problems.
If somebody has a problem,
and you can find a solution for them
then you're in business.
And it may not be a massive
business at the start.
But if you're looking at your friends,
you're looking at your family
and looking at your community.
The people who are already around you.
When they're complaining about something,
when they're frustrated about something,
which is how many conversations
have you had with people where
they're complaining, right.
Lots.
Every time you hear somebody complaining,
look for an opportunity.
Like here's a friend
of mine who is in pain,
who has a need,
huh, can I help them solve that.
Is there an opportunity here?
Does it line up with something
that I'm excited about
that I might be able
to guide them through.
'Cause if you can solve
a problem for a friend
or if you solve a problem for yourself,
if somebody's willing to pay for it,
one person's willing to pay for,
a thousand people willing to pay for.
It can be the start of a new business.
(instrumental music)
Number six is get a part time job.
And again you may be thinking, what?
I thought this was about how
to make money on the side
as an entrepreneur.
Listen, one of the best
things that you can do
to get an education as an entrepreneur
is to go work for somebody
who's done what you want to do.
Yes there is definitely
value in you being out
and you hustling.
You trying to learn everything yourself
and being in the business.
There's also a ton you can learn
from somebody who's already done it.
And so if I had a business
and I wasn't making the money
that I wanted to,
I wasn't making the
impact that I wanted to.
It felt like I should
be growing a lot faster
than I currently was.
I would go try to find somebody
who was in that business,
who has ten employees or less,
who's a company that I look up to,
that I would want to be
in a couple of years,
and find a way to work with them.
Find even some part-time thing,
to work for them freelance,
outsource my services to them,
to be a part of their ecosystem.
To get as close to the
founder as possible,
because the point of getting
the job is not just the money.
It's to learn.
It's to understand how
that industry works.
How they get business,
how they get customers,
how they've grown.
And that take that back to
make your business stronger.
So getting a part-time
job could be a great way
to invest in yourself,
not just to make a paycheck
but to get the education
while getting paid.
Normally you pay for education,
here you're getting paid to learn,
and make yourself better
as an entrepreneur.
(instrumental music)
And number seven is build a foundation.
I think too many people,
when they're looking at
making money on the side,
are just looking for some quick cash,
something that's totally unrelated,
something they don't really care about
or have a passion about.
And if that's your mindset,
then you're always
going to be stuck there.
You're always going to be
in like the next quick deal,
the next quick cash,
the next small thing.
And you're always doing
small deal to small deal
to small deal.
Where if you want to have ultimate success
it's going to come from
building something bigger.
And it starts with having a foundation.
So our YouTube channel as an example.
You may start it off,
and at the beginning you're
not getting a ton of return.
You're not making a lot
of money on advertising.
You're not getting a lot of traction.
Party because you're still
working on your own skills.
'Cause you're not great
at being a YouTuber yet.
It's okay it's a start.
Expect to suck at the start,
that's what happens.
But you're building a foundation.
If you keep working at it,
you keep getting better,
you keep improving.
You keep grinding you keep hustling,
It builds and it builds and
it builds and it builds.
And you start making more money.
And you start making more collaborations,
then you start getting more brand deals.
You start getting more opportunities.
Because every day you're
taking a step forward,
that you can turn this
side thing at the start,
which I'm going to start this
YouTube channel on the side,
which it was for me.
My YouTube channel was a side hustle.
I had my business.
and YouTube was something
that I wanted to experiment with and try.
And I tried it
and I improved, improved,
improved, improved.
I took a break for a while.
I came back to it, improved,
improved, improved, improved.
And now it's a significant chunk
of what I do and where I spend my time.
So always have an eye towards
if I'm picking something that
I want to do on the side.
It's leading towards something bigger.
'Cause if it's not leading
towards something bigger,
then I'm always going to be
stuck playing the small game.
Always going to be stuck
doing the small deals.
And I'm never going to
reach anything massive.
Those are my thoughts.
My seven ways to make money on the side.
Some new ideas for you,
hopefully you enjoyed them.
I'd love to know what did you think?
What was your favorite rule?
What are you going to try to implement
in your business, your life.
Also did I miss an eight, nine, 10?
Is there something you
want to add to the list?
That has helped you that
you want to bring value
to Believe Nation.
I really appreciate it.
Leave it down the comments below.
And we'll join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
Aim whatever your onward is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.